now to a very contentious session in the
u.s senate that was supposed to be
a hearing about masks and what goes
forward but really ended up with a major
disagreement on the origins of the
pandemic
congressional correspondent jackie
heinrich has that part of the story
tonight good evening jackie good evening
brett
at this time the cdc will not reimpose
mass mandates
citing vaccine efficacy and there is
concern that is the wrong
call but in this hearing the only focus
the only fireworks was on covid origins
senator rand paul and dr anthony fauci
trading accusations of lying
knowing that it is a crime to lie to
congress do you wish to retract your
statement of may 11
where you claimed that the nih never
funded gain of function research in
wujon
senator paul i have never lied before
the congress
and i do not retract that statement a
heated aside in a senate hearing
otherwise focused on whether to bring
back
the mask requirement vaccination is the
most powerful tool we have
right now the cdc is not recommending
masks for vaccinated people
despite new data showing the delta
variant first identified in india
now accounts for 83 percent of new u.s
cases
up 50 percent from july 3rd fatalities
also climbed by nearly 50 percent
instead of changing the mass guidance
again the cdc is urging the unvaccinated
to get their shots
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
sternly echoing this is not
complicated get vaccinated ignore all of
these other
voices that are giving demonstrably
bad advice amid stubbornly low
vaccination rates where the virus is
surging a patchwork of cities and
organizations are breaking with the
cdc's advice
l.a county now requires masks indoors
for all
in las vegas they're recommended the
american academy of pediatrics also
defied cdc advice
saying students and staff shot or no
shot should all wear masks
the cdc says only the unvaccinated
should be required we continue to
recommend that schools
implement layered prevention strategies
masks continue to be a critical part of
these layered prevention strategies
former surgeon general jerome adams says
the cdc
is perilously close to a big mistake
like what he called his own misstep
advising against masks early in the
pandemic the cdc's
masked or vaccinated messaging not only
isn't working it's harmful when you have
the la county sheriff
citing cdc guidance when he says i'm not
going to enforce
local health policies and mandates
also in the hearing one piece of cdc
guidance stood out as contradictory to
all the rest they maintain that masks
are not necessary
if you've had the shot but they're not
lifting the mandate on public
transportation or
on airplanes citing transmission of
variants
brett jackie heinrich live on capitol
hill jackie thanks hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else